[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24
comenzó la convención nacional
republicana en la que el actual
mandatario donald trump y el vice
presidente mike pence fueron confirmados
como los candidatos para las elecciones
presidenciales de noviembre el evento se
lleva a cabo al tiempo que hay protestas
en el estado de winsconsin por otro
presunto caso de abuso policial contra
un ciudadano afroamericano
tres personas murieron en una nueva
masacre perpetrada en colombia país que
hace frente a un rebrote de la violencia
en las zonas apartadas por cuenta de la
presencia de grupos delincuenciales y el
narcotráfico con este hecho ya son 45
las masacres que han dejado 180 personas
fallecidas en lo corrido del 2020
y en méxico hoy comenzaron las clases
por televisión una medida del gobierno
para hacer frente al cob y 19 en nuestra
serie de reportajes especiales
hablaremos de los adolescentes durante
los tiempos de pandemia en esta primera
entrega conoceremos el caso de una joven
mexicana que continuó con sus rutinas
habituales dentro de la llamada nueva
normalidad pese al confinamiento ya las
restricciones
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora comenzó en la ciudad de
charlotte en el estado de carolina del
norte la convención del partido
republicano un evento en el que los
delegados de esa formación política no
minaron ya oficialmente a donald trump
ya mike pence como la fórmula para
mantenerse en la casa blanca en
washington el evento a diferencia de la
convención demócrata será una mezcla de
actos virtuales y también de otros
presenciales en los que se esperan a
oradores como la embajadora de eeuu ante
la onu
nicky reilly de algunos familiares del
presidente de trump como sus hijos
donald trump juniors e ivanka entre
otros asistentes invitados en el acto
que daba inicio esta mañana a esta
convención el presidente de donald trump
ha dio algunas palabras a los asistentes
y quiero agradecer a las personas de
carolina del norte porque para ser
honesto con ustedes me siento en la
obligación de estar aquí ustedes tienen
un gobernador que está en ánimo de
cierre total les garantizo que el 4 de
noviembre todo se abrirá todo estará
bien como en otros estados el 4 de
noviembre y ustedes saben esos
gobernadores demócratas ellos llaman el
cierre hasta después de que terminen las
elecciones porque quieren que nuestras
cifras económicas se vean lo peor
posible y las protestas por otro
presunto caso de abuso policial contra
un ciudadano afrodescendiente en el
estado de winsconsin han obligado a
instaurar el toque de queda en las
localidades afectadas por los
enfrentamientos entre los manifestantes
y la fuerza pública
al grito de no retrocederemos los
manifestantes protagonizaron un tenso
enfrentamiento mientras marchaban hacia
el cuartel general de la policía algunos
prendieron fuego a los coches aparcados
y destrozaron los escaparates lo que
llevó a las autoridades a imponer un
toque de queda el motín de que no se en
wisconsin se dio después de otro caso de
aparente uso excesivo de la fuerza
policial contra ciudadanos negros
estamos cansados de esto y en este
momento esta es la generación equivocada
a la que le ocurre esto la frustración
está hirviendo hasta arriba y estamos
enojados y cansados un usuario de
twitter publicó este vídeo filmado el
domingo por la tarde en el se ve a un
hombre negro custodiado por la policía
aunque parece que no obedece sus órdenes
mientras se metía en el vehículo
un policía le disparó por la espalda
siete veces el hombre fue identificado
como jake blake de 29 años según la
policía de que los agentes respondieron
a lo que describieron como un incidente
doméstico los medios locales citaron a
la prometida de play asegurando que el
tiroteo ocurrió frente a sus tres hijos
sin ningún motivo el gobernador del
estado tony hibbert en un tuit mordaz
aseguró que la víctima no era el primer
hombre negro en recibir disparos ni en
ser herido o asesinado sin piedad a
manos de los encargados de hacer cumplir
la ley en eeuu y nos vamos ahora hasta
colombia este país fue escenario de una
nueva masacre perpetrada el domingo en
la noche en la localidad de venecia esto
en el departamento de antioquia en el
noroeste de ese país suramericano según
las autoridades locales tres personas
entre ellas un menor de edad murieron
después de que hombres sin identificar
armados ingresaron en una vivienda y
dispararon de acuerdo con el
observatorio indepaz en el 2020 ya han
tenido lugar 45 masacres en ese país
dejando 180 personas fallecidas aunque
el gobierno
y van dulken insiste en llamar los
asesinatos colectivos e indicar que
solamente han ocurrido siete casos que
han dejado 30 víctimas sembrando una
gran polémica entre la sociedad
colombiana
vamos a conectar con ariel ávila
subdirector del centro del pensamiento
sobre conflicto armado paz y
posconflicto con quien vamos a analizar
este tema nos atiende desde la ciudad de
bogotá muy buenas noches señor ávila
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 y otra masacre en este país
suramericano que es lo que está
sucediendo en colombia que se está
recrudeciendo la violencia en ese país
muy buenas noches y muy amable por su
invitación están ocurriendo los
fenómenos por un lado hay una cosa que
llaman empate técnico negativo después
de la salida de las farc algunos
territorios comenzaron a ser disputados
por organizaciones criminales y después
de tres años ninguna organización
criminal gana entonces hay un conflicto
en degradación donde la población civil
es víctima y lo segundo lo que está
pasando es que tenemos una explosión de
economías ilegales la onza de oro hace
ocho meses estaba en 1200 dólares hoy
está en 2000 dólares entonces y la
cocaína no ha bajado de precio entonces
hay una disputa por economías ilegales
no solo narcotráfico señor ávila el
gobierno culpa como usted lo dice a
grupos delincuenciales a ex integrantes
de los diferentes grupos guerrilleros y
la sociedad mientras tanto está
reclamando justicia la presencia de
estos grupos en estas zonas apartadas de
colombia no es nueva como la quiere
hacer ver el gobierno porque el gobierno
no hace presencia allí porque no actúa
cuando hay alertas tempranas porque este
tipo de escenarios los ha visto colombia
a lo largo de las últimas décadas no es
un fenómeno de los últimos días
mira el gobierno nacional tiene dos
grandes problemas lo primero es que no
entienden lo que está pasando en materia
de seguridad y como no entiende comete
errores entonces culpan al gobierno
anterior que pasó hace más de dos años
culpan incluso al proceso de para lo
cual es contra evidente estadísticamente
y no tienen una estrategia clara de
copamiento territorial por eso es que
salen digamos tienen esas salidas en paz
pero el otro problema que tienen es que
desbarataron todo el andamiaje
institucional que había para que el
estado llegara a esos territorios y
construir estado en esas zonas y ahora
lo están armando es lo mismo que había
antes pero con otro nombre y eso no da
resultados de un día para otro entonces
por eso hay zonas que literalmente ya se
salieron de las manos y así ocurran
políticas grandes va a ser imposible que
se solucione rápidamente señor ávila
fuera de colombia llama mucho la
atención este debate que están dando los
medios colombianos y la sociedad de ese
país porque el gobierno los califica
estas estas muertes como asesinos
asesinatos colectivos los medios los
llaman masacre está el gobierno tratando
de mitigar el impacto que puede tener
esto en la sociedad está tratando de
restarle importancia porque está
teniendo lugar allí
básicamente porque este gobierno cuando
ganó las elecciones se vendió como el
gobierno de la seguridad como fue su
mentor el ahora preso álvaro uribe vélez
ex presidente y ex senador y por tanto
fallar en seguridad es fallar en su
agenda central por eso han convertido
esto un debate semántico pero mira más
allá hay algunos cruces entre
periodistas y el ministro de defensa
esto pues se llaman masacres así han
sido catalogadas por todos los centros
de investigación universidades y propias
instituciones muchas gracias señor ariel
ávila desde la ciudad de bogotá por
analizar este tema para nosotros aquí en
france 24 vamos a cambiar de tema ahora
demos un vistazo al avance que tiene la
pandemia del coronavirus del cobi 19
para este día lunes comienzo de semana
al día de hoy hay 23 millones 528 mil
652 personas contagiadas con este virus
15 mil 15 millones 215 mil 800 11
personas ya se han recuperado
satisfactoriamente y 810 mil 340
personas han fallecido en todo el mundo
hay expectativa por el caso de un hombre
de 33 años un residente en la ciudad
que según los registros ha sido
contagiado con kobe 19 dos veces este
mismo año mientras tanto en nuestra
región brasil perú méxico colombia y
chile son los países que más casos de
contagio están registrando hasta el
momento
y en méxico hoy comenzaron las clases
por televisión muchas familias han
tenido que retirar a sus hijos de las
escuelas privadas y pasarlos al sistema
público debido a la crisis económica que
también ha desatado la pandemia en ese
país latinoamericano esto también genera
un reto muy importante para el gobierno
mexicano se lo contamos en el siguiente
reportaje
desde hace 21 años erika terán tiene el
jardín de niños y estancia infantil un
mundo del nuevo milenio y en los últimos
6 meses lo que ha construido está a
punto de venirse abajo pues los papás de
80% de los niños no pueden pagar ya las
cuotas y se han ido con lo que pasó de
la pandemia
estella me es muy difícil de traer a a
mi hija por falta de recursos el
panorama para erika es incierto esta
situación de la pandemia vino a
afectarnos se podría decir a un 100 por
ciento estamos tomando la decisión de
probablemente cerrar para el próximo mes
por la falta de niños en méxico hay
40.000 escuelas privadas de todos los
niveles y cerca de 15.000 de ellas
especialmente de primaria y secundaria
enfrentan dificultades y cuando pase el
periodo de inscripciones se verá cuántas
habrán tenido que cerrar los estudiantes
que se están saliendo en términos
generales va a ser alrededor de más de
millón y medio de estudiantes que han
estado desertando de las escuelas
particulares se lo están viendo a las
escuelas oficiales las autoridades
aseguran que tienen capacidad
para enfrentar esta realidad esa
migración que se dé de escuelas privadas
de forma natural por la condición
económica en méxico tenemos 200 mil
escuelas en básica en el país y un
millón doscientos mil maestros de manera
que están preparados para recibir esta
migración el sub-secretario es optimista
no así las madres que no tendrán quien
les cuidan sus hijos si cierran las
estancias privadas por la crisis
mi hija come desayuna aquí todos los
días de lunes a viernes
y el que lo cierre me afecta demasiado
porque yo trabajo trabajo y yo no tengo
el tiempo para poder estar con ella en
las tardes además de dueños de escuelas
padres y alumnos otros afectados son los
maestros pues según la asociación de
escuelas particulares unos 200.000
trabajadores del sector educativo
podrían quedarse sin trabajo a lo largo
de esta semana les presentaremos una
serie de reportajes especiales sobre los
adolescentes durante los tiempos de
pandemia de kobe 19 en esta primera
entrega nos vamos a ir hasta méxico para
conocer a una joven de 15 años de la
ciudad de villahermosa que logró
adaptarse a la llamada nueva realidad
hola me llamo de lago ness tengo 15 años
de tabasco al principio si sentía mucho
aburrimiento al estar encerrada en mi
casa porque no hacía nada por el paso
del tiempo es mi escuela igual tomó las
medidas de tomar clases en línea también
si me ha afectado el no salir ya que yo
he acostumbrado mucho a salir todos los
fines de semana con mis amigos con mi
familia he aprovechado muchísimas cosas
así como los cursos que están dando
ahorita en línea este necesito alguna de
repostería metió uno de inglés y me metí
uno de ballet que normalmente
acostumbramos a hacer festivales en los
teatros y ahorita se tomó una medida de
hacerlos por medio de zoom de la
plataforma azul y ha tenido dos
méxico lo veía tan lejos y tan
superficial que al principio no se lo
tomó nada en serio hasta que vieron los
casos cómo iban aumentando poco a poco
por ejemplo aquí en tabasco los casos
están muy altos desde uno de los estados
más contagiados que hay en el en el país
cuando el gobierno indique que el
semáforo está en verde me gustaría mucho
regresar a la escuela con estudios
presenciales a mis clases de baile poder
viajar visitar a mi familia lo que estoy
aprendiendo durante esta pandemia al
estar en casa es obviamente a ser
tolerante a mejorar la convivencia con
mi familia aprender a estar todos juntos
en un lugar cerrado al igual cómo
mantenerme ocupada como por ejemplo a
estar cocinando a estar bailando tomar
clases de baile de diferente tipo
[Música]
en otros temas las autoridades de
belarús detuvieron a 13 de los
coordinadores de las manifestaciones que
han tenido lugar en el centro de minsk
la capital de ese país europeo el
anuncio de esta detención fue dado a
conocer por el consejo de coordinación o
una organización que fue creada por la
oposición política del país para
negociar con el presidente alexander
lukachenko una transición de poder
en india al menos 90 personas entre
ellas varios menores de edad quedaron
atrapados bajo los escombros de un
edificio que colapsó en la ciudad de
mumbai y la edificación de cinco plantas
se vino abajo por razones que son
investigadas por las autoridades locales
de acuerdo con los primeros reportes
unas 28 personas fueron sacadas de los
escombros con vida por parte de los
equipos de rescate pese a las intensas
lluvias monzónicas que dificultaron la
búsqueda de los sobrevivientes y de los
heridos las actividades de rescate
continuo
es todo por el momento aquí en las
noticias de france 24 siga con nuestra
programación feliz noche para todos
[Música]